ben vous avez suivi ce discours de joe
biden 800 millions de soutien militaire
plus donc un soutien supplémentaire de
800 millions pour les ukrainiens joe
biden frappe fort
oui d'abord dubaï donne justifie l'aide
américaine à l'ukraine désormais par les
atrocités et les crimes de guerre
constaté après le retrait russe d abord
de kiev ces derniers jours pour joe
biden ces crimes constatés impose à
l'amérique de se tenir aux côtés de
l'ukraine dans cette nouvelle phase qui
s'ouvre donbass et qui semble le
préoccuper vous l'avez dit 800 millions
de dollars d'armes seront donc livré à
l'ukraine dès les prochains jours des
munitions des armes légères des drones
tactiques et des systèmes d'armes
antichars en grand nombre ici l'aide
financière et militaire accordée à
l'ukraine fait plutôt consensus du côté
républicain ou démocrate
même si joe biden a annoncé avant même
le début de l'offensive le 24 février
vous vous en souvenez qu'aucun soldat
américain ne serait directement impliqué
dans le conflit la question de la
belligérance pendant cette belligérance
américaine se pose réellement sous le
dôme du congrès or si moscou devait
décréter que l'implication d'armes
américaines en provenance des états unis
fait de l'américain belligérants
justement cela appuierait l'escaladé du
conflit ce que redoutent les alliés
européens après l'avoir formulée à joe
biden annonce donc à nouveau volet de
sanctions financières également contre
la russie une aide de 500 millions de
dollars en numéraire à kiev tout en
peinant à tracer les lignes rouges clair
sur le plan militaire